hello bros in case you haven't notice
there's a subscribe button down there if
you want to hit it feel free to do so
just if you like the video of course
which you haven't watched yet just want
to remind you guys in every single video
I ever make about that roll the intro
last week I asked you leave your entry Z
oh sorry did I forget ever tell about my
merch that's right if you want to check
out the hottest merch in the game go to
red percent comm size P to PI right now
and check it out
keep the interim closed sorry did I
forget to mention ass is coming out on
every single console ever in May please
do check that out sorry guys we didn't
actually play the internet sorry I was
getting lonely where did you go
the intro is so long there's not enough
me in love why just what you know what
just Rolly I don't care anymore just
fine I am wearing silly glasses let's
review the Y memes from last week I've
been sneaking some and giggling to
myself softly that's about as funny as
you guys get just so you know we're on
the same level we attract each other
where there's a balance thing okay we
have the same humor and we're a group of
intellectuals there's nothing more to it
now let's review the memes I've never
been judged by your skin colour just was
take back everything I just said earth
angel PewDiePie is Johnny D's earth
angel wait what a pleasant good evening
to all of his supporters and followers I
am here for two reasons one of that is
to extend our sincere gratitude to
PewDiePie for all the help that he has
extended to us he was like a
gorgeous angel - Johnny D yes man I I
can't take this stuff I really really
appreciate this the positive sentiments
I didn't do anything okay if anything
I'm the one that got Johnny D in trouble
in the first place you guys were the
ones that helped Johnny D I just
delivered the message honestly like I
genuinely mean that I feel uncomfortable
getting this sort of praise when I I
haven't earned it does anyone still
remember doki-doki
gunshots honestly it translates so much
better with doki-doki than stupid
whatever the show is called PewDiePie
neon art whoa did not expect that
goddamn that sexy I like all the fan art
the people have been working on for a
long time or they're just all outdated
now because I shave
that's very cool though thank you very
much Harold raver E now back to the
garbage memes easiest way to suicide
Creighton oh it's Google vs. Bing what
is gaming say Oh No 99% really oh that's
brilliant well done Bing well it seems
like I'm gonna have to switch to Bing
from now on alphys love a kid I've seen
this would that's how you know you're
alpha if you're hey pop gee shucks
fortnight - ah they're best friends how
wholesome when does the battery all meme
gonna die honestly like it's fun for a
while
PewDiePie what's the best thing in the
world boy me oh my god you're so mean I
hate you Peter Pan commits suicide boy
visits Peter pice grave name review this
is so sad can we post another outdated
meme that's right I already reviewed it
there's no reason to keep it going
The Adventures of pew pew oh I'm not
actually wearing the hat to promo my new
merch represent DICOM / peopie check it
out it's just because I don't let you
oh I miss Edgar so much this will be the
last of why I'm doing in Japan by the
way top 10 anime portrayals of all time
yeah it went south real fast
honestly all great memes mistake all
great memes must come to an end I'm not
one of you guys that just linger with
all the memes he said the barrel jokes
okay I realized what things have to stop
I'm not the one keep posting about the
chair meme can you do this can you do
that
super cringe to me right now okay don't
even bother with chair memes cuz I'm way
past them by now okay I bet you still
like chair means don't you
great logic Felix play USSR anthem in
your video reviews love memes wear
Adidas and goorsha
swear in Russia release suka be at merch
don't [ __ ] wait what it's worldwide
shipping what are you talking about look
ships worldwide are we lying about that
oh I'll talk to represent see when I kid
- oh my god I love all these
water-cooled CPUs yeah isn't it great
where is the PT PI family I miss them
that was a weird era of PewDiePie I
don't know I don't know if we need to
bring that back to be honest I think
that the white walls really speaks for
itself I don't need some flashy imagery
and a bunch of distracting things in the
background to hide the fact that I'm
really not that entertaining I got the
editors for that pubes sick of yet
notice me are a cowboy very cool
too bad it's outdated now honestly the
very dope I I really appreciate all the
Fanta I thank you very much
took me a lot of time yeah it sure looks
like it
Mira Chisum younger on top varney
Mukunda Donna Martin is alibi takraw
Maharajah little do Kabylia in Abunda
muscle ina Lavoie on a 9r which are in
shape what the talkative a Sullinger
endo del Sol eco injury in the devasena
save a Leonardo valentín EO kabuki Raman
are low poly keep on pain - tone - maybe
change other than one tomato jst another
calcium nevada Kazu
[Music]
that's funny that's exactly what happens
every time when you're shooting up the
school and come across the guy who once
lend you a pen okay
can we make yeah we can make that joke
no we can't Brad - we'll put it in
against my will when my name isn't a
math problem and all the class stares at
me
that's right B word I bought 60
watermelons that is so funny you guys
honestly this is this is the top of
stuff I I've been we've been doing how
many episodes 20 30 and finally we have
some really good memes here as you post
it as two thousand nine hundred of you
uploaded so funnily hey good you know
what good for you guys
honestly that is so great Siri I'm so
proud I am so proud right now this is
the father moment that I can cherish
that's right I didn't even have to shave
I just go back in time that's one of my
many many super special abilities the
thief is back he's now stolen pewds
forehead I didn't want to talk about
this but it is true
Jack's film has stolen my forehead one
of many things he will steal how far
would this man go at what point am I
supposed to stop joking about this and
be serious I'm sick of it I'm sick and
tired of it oh my how about a nice cup
of Pew news anyone please bread one and
bread - please don't cut this out this
is gold who knows only Brad one and Brad
two can tell I am merely just a
messenger when you hear someone clapping
and it's so annoying how its shaped
anytime I clap I'm like now I gotta say
it man review how beauties Brad how
viewers sieve spread what pride actually
is not don't post Brad's ego even
further
please we don't need that proof
of great handshaking skills wait what I
remember that he wouldn't he went in for
a handshake and I had to adjust myself
and why are you filming me make me angry
we're gonna analyze every single moment
of this okay all right slow-mo way huh
is he not going in for a handshake here
huh you see the angle it's like down not
up huh
look at that he's trying to mess with me
son of a garbage huh look at that he
changes I go in for the handshake as
well I'm like okay all right we're doing
this he changes
he changes but I'm like not fam nah I
got you wait what oh my god it's super
detail let me zoom out a little bit
they're disrespecting women I see it I
take off my headphones stop a respect
wow man what what are you gonna do I
have this he is right I don't have a gun
[Laughter]
Jesus Christ that is terrifying looks
like a blood-borne character or
something
it's terrifying some oozing machi
Skechers IV our feet gnomes very nice a
very nice Jack got married time to copy
him pewds nice try my oh that's good
what next hello it's me from the future
the video just stopped working I don't
know what happened so I figured
something happened in the meanwhile you
may have heard about it that's right me
and my sister got engaged finally what
took you so long feelings so I thought
why don't I just finish this video off
by reacting to your reaction to the day
engagement
since the South Korea North Korea
finally got together they saw my
proposal and they they were just so
moved by it she said she'll think about
it ah what a beautiful moment she said
yes
spoilers she said yes félix proposing
tomorrow Xia leaked footage I really
wanted to do something cute like maybe
have my eye involved maybe like I could
hide the ring in a little backpack or
something like that but my eyes is there
by the dog the pugs are in UK we're
still in Japan this is by the end of our
trip so I wanted to do it at the end of
the trip because it's been such an
amazing trip when Marcia says he's not
gonna marry a bearded guy because he
looked like a terrorist mm-hmm come on
if you're gonna propose you got to look
your best which is why I got the duck
haircut of course I planned this for a
long time there you go everybody
I don't know this probably changed the
whole mood of the video I don't know but
I'm just so lucky I'm so happy this said
like I said this has been the best trip
of my life I'm I'm so thankful for
everything and especially right now I
mean to get all mopey I'm just very
happy that's it for this video don't
forget to buy a merch eight days left
guys
can we smash it good goodbye
with a patient I'm never gonna switch
what can you do how's it going you wanna
hit a floating city and I'm never gonna
fly tell me when it go I'm like whenever
I'm done with this pass to make the
Edgar